could even jump you know Brad as the
president was leaving this afternoon to
go to San Diego he said that he's nearly
got the cabinet and the staff where he
wants it to be which is an indication
that there may still be some changes
ahead and one of the potential changes
that could be happening is according to
the Associated Press Trading out
secretary Shulkin at the Department of
Veterans Affairs for Rick Perry who is
currently the energy secretary the
president is really a big fan of Rick
Perry David Shulkin has run into some
problems a little controversy over his
travel the president certainly would
like to put Rick Perry with his long
track record of helping veterans into a
position like that
now as to what happened today we first
reported the likelihood that this was
going to happen to you last fall and
that is getting rid of Rick stellar soon
as the Secretary of State in putting in
Mike Pompeo the CIA director well about
five months after we first reported it
finally happened this morning it was not
a surprise it had been rumored for
months but the sudden announcement that
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson was
fired sent shockwaves through Washington
we got along actually quite well but we
disagreed on things when you look at the
Iran deal I think it's terrible I guess
it was okay President Trump made the
decision last week White House officials
say chief of staff John Kelly called
Tillerson who was traveling in Africa on
Friday to tell him he'd have to step
aside officials say Tillerson asked
Kelly if the president would wait until
he returned Tillerson touched down in DC
at 4:00 a.m. today five hours later
President Trump tweeted Mike Pompeo
director of the CIA will become our new
Secretary of State he will do a
fantastic job thank you to Rex Tillerson
for his service meeting the press this
afternoon Tillerson did not sound happy
in the least I received a call today
from the president States a little after
noon time from Air Force One what is
most important is to ensure an orderly
of smooth transition during a time that
the country continues to face
significant policy
national security challenges the White
House says the timing was driven in part
by last week's announcement of a
possible meeting between President Trump
and North Korea's Kim jong-un president
Trump wanted a new team in place for
that process and the numerous trade
deals the president wants to renegotiate
and he simply loves Mike Pompeo
tremendous energy tremendous intellect
we're always on the same wavelength
teller since firing prompted Swift
reaction from the president's opponents
on Capitol Hill what President Trump did
and the way he did it once again
indicates the chaos in this
administration I've never seen a
presidential administration so basically
disorganized at war with one another
creating such huge problems for the
country to replace Pompeo at CI a
president Trump chose career CIA
official Gina Hass Bell she would be the
first woman to ever lead the spy agency
but Haspel Senate confirmation is
already drawing fire over her
involvement in the CIA black site
operations in the early 2000s the
extraordinary rendition and
waterboarding of terror suspects had a
good working relationship to last year
but rightfully there are a lot of
questions to be asked filling the
position of his soon-to-be departed
chief economic adviser Gary Cohen is
also on the president's mind the
president revealing that economist and
television host Larry Kudlow
is a leading candidate to fill the post
I've known him a long time we don't
agree on everything but in this case I
think that's good I want to have the
divergent opinions
we agree on most he now has come around
to believing in tariffs as also a
negotiating point all of this his
president Trump was heading to
California to view prototypes for a
border wall if you didn't have walls
over here you wouldn't even have a
country and by the way the state of
California is begging us to build walls
in certain areas they don't tell you
that the president favors a wall with a
see-through component so Border Patrol
can know what's going on on the other
side his big problem Democrats continue
to refuse to give him the money to build
it there was one other staff change at
the White House this one coming as a bit
of a surprise itself it happened
yesterday the president so-called body
man the former UConn quarterback Johnny
McEntee would suddenly let go and
escorted from the grounds of the White
House the details surrounding his
departure still remained murky though he
did almost immediately land a job at the
Trump campaign but Elijah Cummings on
Capitol Hill a Democratic congressman
wants some answers and is asking the
White House for all of the records
pertaining to McEntee 's security
clearance brett john roberts live in the
North Lawn John thanks